the national debate over transgenderism
and specifically transgenderism in
elementary and middle schools has
focused on three things
biology psychology and theology three
questions what is a woman what is gender
and who are we
but there's a fourth aspect that's
gotten very little attention and maybe
playing a larger role in this
transgender phenomenon than most people
seem to know money
who's paying
when the white house promoted puberty
blockers for little kids last week
transgender transitioning for little
kids
the study that the white house cited as
the scientific basis for this program
came from a group called the trevor
project
the trevor project is an lgbt non-profit
organization funded by the donations of
individuals and corporations now
according to a new report from chuck
ross at the washington free beacon
turns out two of the corporations that
fund the trevor project are ab vi
and allergan
pharmaceutical companies that make the
drugs and medical products that are used
in the transgender transitioning process
both companies gave at least fifty
thousand dollars to the trevor project
but the trevor project never disclosed
the donations they never disclosed the
obvious conflict of interest
the government's argument for
transitioning kids rests on a study
funded by the companies that most stand
to benefit from the government promoting
the transitioning of kids and they all
justify the medical experimentation on
little kids on the grounds that the
interventions will reduce the kids risk
of suicide when they get older
but it turns out that science is totally
bunk too
just a few years ago a group of
scientists including a physician who
participated in clinical research for
abvay
wrote in a letter for the journal of
clinical endocrinology
that the transgender drugs for kids
could cause sterility
sexual dysfunction and heart disease
without any proof of long-term success
in suicide prevention
in other words
the white house is peddling child abuse
based on bunk science commissioned by a
left-wing non-profit funded by the
companies selling the child abuse we are
living in a time of unprecedented
upheaval economic social and political
people don't even know what a woman is
anymore
and even still at least one political
rule endures he who pays the piper calls
the tune i'm michael knowles this is the
michael knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from angela ausmas
gill who says
a fetus is an item
just like a black person used to be
considered property wow yes this is in
reference to this horrible story out of
dc where
five babies just obviously undeniably
full-term babies were aborted meaning
they were killed it was just outright
infanticide there were photos of this
and the authorities are not doing
anything to the people who killed the
babies and they're actually prosecuting
the people who blew the whistle on it
and and the contradiction here
is that they were referring to
the babies as items that were taken out
of the home but they're prosecuting the
the pro-lifer because
of the way that she was treating dead
bodies
so the babies are bodies for the purpose
of of prosecuting the pro-lifers but the
babies are items for the purpose of
letting the killers off the hook it's an
obvious contradiction you say it's
similar to treating black people like
people for the purposes in the old south
of say representation in the government
right the three-fifths compromise but
treating them like property for the
purposes of their actual rights yes
that's true and it's why i got in
trouble a little while ago for making
this point it's why
abortion is not only similar to slavery
it's much worse if you have a problem
with slavery i think we all do if you
have a problem with slavery then the
issues of abortion are much much worse
because while slavery deprives someone
of his liberty
abortion deprived someone of his life on
the same kind of sick arguments it's
sick and we've got to articulate these
things we've got to do them ourselves
we've got to we've got to make this this
argumentation and this persuasion
ourselves now when we want to do other
things ourselves like fix up our car you
got to check out rockauto.com right now
go to
rockauto.com and write knowles in there
how did you hear about us box
prices are going through the roof
this is because of rampant inflation
among other things every every time you
go to fill up the gasoline in your car
what are you probably paying double what
you were paying a year ago
in some places every the car has been
very expensive for me
so what are you going to do i'm going to
give you two scenarios you can either go
to the brick and mortar auto parts store
and you can drive over there that's what
15 minutes of your time then you got to
stand and wait in line then you got to
get peppered with questions by the guy
behind the counter then he goes behind
the counter he doesn't have the part
that you want he comes back out he
orders it online you got to drive home
you got to drive back in about a week
and you got to pay twice as much that's
one thing you can do if you're a dummy
or you can go to rockauto.com a family
company that has served auto parts
customers online for 20 years same
prices for pros and do-it-yourselfers no
gimmicks no wake up at 3 am to say 15 no
reliably low prices super easy to
navigate catalog even i can navigate it
go to rockauto.com see all the parts
available for your car or truck and then
write knowles in there how did you hear
about us box so they know that we sent
you
you want to talk about medical
corruption gosh we've had medical
corruption
up to our eyeballs for the past couple
of years
now we're seeing it with this
transgender issue for kids obvious
conflicts of interest a lot of people
making money on outright child abuse but
what about the last two years of medical
corruption where the the so-called
medical authorities have lied to us have
misled us every single turn shut down
our lives closed our businesses kept us
out of church had our loved ones dying
alone all because the exalted dr fauci
would wake up every morning and based on
his whims would decree how we're all
going to live wear the masks don't wear
the masks keep locking down lockdowns
are bad actually they're good again on
and on and on and on and everyone
believes everyone you sweet summer
children you really believe
maybe not you if you're listening to
this show you're probably a little more
with it than most most people believe
that kovid's over
because they sent fouchy into witness
protection because they've moved on now
biden is talking about
ukraine or biden is talking about some
other issue
and they've it's if the kovid mess was
hurting democrats in the polls it's an
election year so they're not talking
about it anymore and i told you you know
i hate to say i told you so you know i
hate to put on my no stradamas hat
but i told you it's not going away
they're going to bring kovid back the
moment that it's politically convenient
they're going to do it by never got rid
of the national emergency authorization
they still haven't gotten rid of masks
on airplanes they're still holding out
the masking for kids under five in new
york city they're still asking you and
sometimes telling you outright to get
the 57th booster shot it's not over
they've kept the power that they've been
taking for the past two years and now
from the new york times
the new york times says covid19 is
coming back again
here's how to prepare this is your
checklist from the new york times for
how to prepare for the new wave of
covid19
one pay attention to covet indicators in
your community two have high quality
masks on hand three order home covid
tests sooner rather than later you need
to know if you have a mild cough get a
booster when you're eligible i think
we're up to what number are we up to now
93 or 104 well whatever it is get your
booster because of how effective the
vaccines are that's why you need to keep
getting your boosters get a pulse
oximeter that's a new one i didn't know
i had to get one of those make a plan
for anti-viral drug treatment but not
ivermectin and not hydroxychloroquine
and not anything that any conservative
has done just get whatever drug fouch is
selling have backup plans for social
events and travel this is what you need
to do to prepare and let me just very
quickly
no
no
no definitely no
don't know what that is but no
no
and no i think i'm going to keep my
plans i'm not going to do any of this
like nancy pelosi at the state of the
union
not making any plans covet is over in
the knolls household really it never
began
we had kovit but we got kovid now twice
that's fine glad to say it's fine we're
here we're living it's cool
the covid lockdown measures
never existed in the knolls household we
mocked it from day one
we're going to continue to mock it just
tell them no this obviously has nothing
to do with science this has everything
to do with politics this especially has
to do with the midterm elections
that the libs are going to try to gin up
covet again and push the widespread mail
in ballots and give themselves quite an
advantage at the ballot box so
uh no the the new wave of kovid may be
coming at the new york times
headquarters not going to be coming
here fauci isn't giving up though
even though the powers that be are
trying to put him into witness
protection because he's damaging their
poll numbers he's coming out he's even
suggesting the prospect of another
lockdown
it depends on utilizing a lockdown
in a positive way as opposed to just
thinking you're going to hide from the
virus forever
we need to utilize it in a positive way
well how the hell have you been
utilizing it for the last two years i
wish you thought about utilizing them in
a positive way two years ago people
sometimes ask me how fauchy gets away
with it
how how has fouchy stuck in power for 40
years if you want to find out the full
answer to this we've got a three part
docu series on daily wire it's one of
the most popular products we've ever put
out for the daily wire audience might be
number one it's fouchy unmasked you can
get that today at dailywire.com it's the
whole story what you've never heard
before which you've never seen before
and it's important because they're going
to bring this little jerk back one of
the ways that dr fauci has maintained
power is that dr fauci is never wrong
he's never wrong because he's always
said the right thing
in addition to the wrong thing because
dr fauci holds both sides of every
single issue that's ever been put before
him
uh the clearest example is the masks
wear them at don't wear the masks wear
the mask sometimes wear the masks always
wear the masks but it's true of
lockdowns too dr fatchett said lockdowns
don't work then dr fatchi also says
lockdowns do work he's been doing this
since the 1980s he's been doing this for
his entire career
so now we're going to have to maybe
utilize lockdowns in a positive way
we're probably going to have to utilize
those lockdowns in a really positive way
for democrats right before the midterm
elections so no one can go out there and
vote in person so we're all going to
send in mail-ins and then magically all
the democrats are going to win or at
least they're going to stop the title
wave that the polls show for republicans
right now fouchy and this ties back into
the point that we were talking about at
the top fauci has been the most
aggressive the most belligerent
on
fighting the virus
right we have to we cannot take into
consideration economic
thoughts uh national security our civil
rights no we have to do everything we
can keep your foot on the pedal to to
keep fighting the virus
but we're not allowed to talk about
where the virus came from we can't talk
about
china
we spoke to one of the who investigators
who've been to wuhan to investigate how
the virus started and they were
prevented from seeing key details and
and from speaking to key people why do
you think the chinese government did
that
you know um
i don't want to create any or or mention
any any disparaging remarks about that
but the chinese are very closed uh
in a way of being very reluctant
particularly when you have a disease
that evolves in their country they
become
extremely secretive even though there's
no reason to be secretive i think they
were very concerned and maybe
embarrassed
that the virus evolved from their
country but there's nothing wrong with
that so
when they see something evolving in
their own country they tend to have a
natural reflex
of not necessarily covering things up
but not being very open and transparent
i don't listen i'm not going to
criticize china and actually what he's
going to do is cover up for china like
he's been doing from the very beginning
that's when he wasn't funding the wuhan
laboratory which he also lied about why
though why is the american ruling class
all of them everywhere in the media in
entertainment in the government and why
are they carrying water for china
because china is buying up all the
resources in our country china owns our
debt china has given crooked deals to
joe biden for goodness sakes the bidens
have made millions of dollars because of
china china's been buying up hollywood
buying up entertainment and he who pays
the piper calls the tune
poor joe biden
i never thought joe biden was
particularly in control of this
government
biden is an empty suit biden is merely
an avatar for the political
establishment the deep state the
administrative state call it whatever
you want he's always been that way for
his entire career and especially now
that his brain has made a pudding and he
doesn't know which end is up but nowhere
was this clearer
than just
just yesterday barack obama came back to
the white house
everyone was very excited to hear obama
speak
and at the reception
no one wanted to talk to joe
there he is
joe's looking around he's trying to wave
and says hello to someone tries to get
their eye i know and then he turns
around he's everyone's talking to obama
here's joe who's gonna talk to me the
president of the united states
each and every one of us at some point
in our lives
has been this guy at a party but we
don't really know anyone there
and we're sort of uh am i who am i
supposed to talk to should i go join
that conversation and i know maybe i'll
just kind of walk around and should i go
maybe it's getting kind of late maybe
i'll get out of here now the difference
of course
is that joe biden does know everyone in
that room because he's at the white
house and the other difference is none
of us has ever been the president of the
united states when you're the president
of the united states people generally
want to talk to you
you're a pretty influential and
important person you're never left
wandering alone
at the party
what this reveals is not merely this
awkward sad excruciating moment for joe
biden
it reveals that he's not really where
the power is
everyone wants to talk to obama obama's
still wielding a lot of power
but in the white house does anyone
really believe that joe biden is the one
calling the shots no you know how we
know that because joe biden will go out
and give speeches notably on ukraine and
then
five seconds later the white house will
contradict him and then he will
contradict what he had previously said
and go along with whatever the white
house says isn't joe biden supposed to
be the white house when we talk about
the white house we're using an object to
refer to the president usually but no
now we're not we're we're using the
object to refer to the broad
faceless nameless power structure that
doesn't seem to give a damn about what
joe biden thinks or really to even say
hello to him
democracy
our democracy that we hear so much about
from the libs doesn't seem to be all
that democratic it seems like there is
more of a permanent kind of bureaucratic
apparatus that's actually running the
show and when even when joe biden claims
to have gotten 87 gazillion votes the
most votes ever he's the most popular
guy in the world
no one really cares no one really cares
what he has to say speaking of our
democracy i would be remiss if i didn't
mention that i your humble host and the
grave threat to democracy
this according to the yale daily news
i will be going to yale
next week with senator cruz he and i are
going to be doing an episode of our
verdict podcast there live
and the yale daily news is encouraging
people not to attend according to this
opinion column from a freshman
at yale cruz and knowles are speaking do
not go
the argument for why i am it talks about
how
senator cruz is a threat to democracy
because he supported trump and that's
terrible but i'm a threat to democracy
apparently because on on the anniversary
of january 6th i implored people to
remember quote the wise men who traveled
a great distance for their leader the
true leader of us all in defiance of an
unjust government
i
i am not
saddened that someone is attacking me in
the yale daily news frankly that brings
me back to my youth it's been a solid
decade since that's happened and it
brings back happy memories i am upset
however
that these supposedly educated yalies
don't get my excellent feast of the
epiphany joke that i told on january 6th
about the wise men following their true
leader okay that's fine
[Music]
the student goes on let's be clear ted
cruz and michael knowles are guilty of
chipping away
at democracy
this is a terrible thing we should care
about democracy quote holding fast to
democracy starts at the local level by
refusing crews and knolls and audience
you have a method of intervention buy
tickets but don't attend
that's a genius move pay us not to do
anything
you you're showing us hey by the way if
you send me just venmo payments right
now to michael knowles that'll really
show me that'll teach me a lesson so and
the more money you send the more of a
lesson i'm going to learn libs
checks are fine too you can make them
out to cash that'll ouch that'll hurt
that'll sting
refuse to legitimize the event he writes
you signal to other yale students and to
the organization that invited them that
democracy is non-negotiable and that you
refuse to normalize the normal the
abnormal rather this is what good civic
action looks like there are many ways to
do this i'm only suggesting one yale is
an influential cultural political and
economic institution
yale st this is my favorite line of the
whole piece
yale students
flush with that great power
hold the great responsibility to fight
for a more just and healthy democracy
democracy is non-negotiable don't don't
go see crews and knowles
okay
the reason i bring this up is not merely
to make fun of the truly grandiose
notions
that uh
18 year olds at yale have about their
place in society and their their role in
america it is our we must defend we 18
year old yale students are the great
bulwark against tyranny we must wield
our great power
of
picking a few classes and going to
parties on the weekends we must wield
that power to
save democracy but it's because of this
word democracy because they keep using
that word democracy and democracy does
not mean
i think what they think it means
ted cruz whether you like him or not
is a united states senator he was
elected by the people of texas
he is
a
as representative of american democracy
as it gets
i do not hold elected office
i have a podcast i have a few podcasts
they're pretty popular podcasts
they get lots and lots hundreds and
hundreds of thousands of views sometimes
over a million views
i'm not saying that means that i am a
representative of
american democracy but it does mean that
there is an audience for this that's at
least some of the american people
want to hear what i have to say and want
to engage with the kind of reporting
that we're bringing here and the kind of
stories that we're that we're discussing
that would be to a smaller degree
representative of american democracy and
i would suspect
that
senator cruz and i are a little more
representative of american democracy
than an 18 year old at yale
so why does the 18 year old at yale
think that he is the great defender of
democracy because he's not really
talking about
democracy when the libs use the word
democracy what they really mean is
liberalism or progressivism or leftism
or whatever word you want to use but
this explains how
a united states senator speaking is
anti-democratic but
some extraordinarily
unrepresentative
elite
far left people are speakers for
democracy this explains how in 2016 when
the people vote for donald trump that's
an assault on democracy this explains
how in hungary when the people vote for
victor orban who is a conservative
leader there that's all reported
everywhere in the west as an assault on
democracy because it has nothing to do
with democracy and it has everything to
do
with liberalism and i think it has
everything to do with the liberal and
ultimately then progressive view of the
world which is that
there is a clear ending point for
history there is a cl there is a clear
political end that we are going to the
arc of history is long but it bends
toward justice and by justice the libs
mean their political program
and it this is good for everybody and we
should all know it and so any time that
an election doesn't go the way that
liberals want it to
by definition that election was
illegitimate this is why the libs don't
respect the results of the 2016 election
this kid at yale has a problem with
senator cruz raising questions about the
2020 election which was by far the most
corrupt election in the last 100 years
at the presidential level this is an
election where they changed all the
rules right beforehand and where in some
states they held the election in
violation of the state constitution like
in pennsylvania
this is an election where there are lots
and lots of questions
and yet if you raise questions about
that election you're a threat to
democracy if you raise questions about
the 2016 election which was a perfectly
ordinary election which was not
conducted during a global pandemic with
widespread mail-in ballots where the
worst thing they could claim occurred in
2016 is that the russians spent a
hundred grand on facebook ads the daily
wire spends that on facebook ads in what
like two hours that's nothing compared
to what you would see
in terms of an actual
interfering campaign in an election
and yet they say that's illegitimate
it's only illegitimate because the
conservative won
and i can't wait i look the event the
this advice isn't really all that wise
in the yale daily news because the event
that we i've got with senator cruz sold
out within about two seconds so
it's already sold out but i would
encourage people to stand in the waiting
line
we're going to get out there we're going
to spread some conservative views to a
campus that has gone extremely left and
it's going to be a great deal of fun
this is this is where the fight is at
this is why what you're seeing in
virginia and florida even in south
dakota now the political fight to stop
the radical left is focusing on the
schools that's where it should be the
schools the classrooms are a crystal
ball to show you what your country is
going to look like in 20 years you know
drew clavin just released a new book
it's called the truth and beauty i
cannot recommend it enough
after years of studying the gospels
trying to find the true meaning of
jesus's words
drew is ready to share his thoughts on
this and drew has come to christianity
in a kind of unusual way he was a
liberal intellectual literary figure for
most of his life and then he was
baptized i think at age 50.
he he he figured out he figured his way
out of the secular leftist materialism
that has brought so much damage on the
world the book is terrific it's part
memoir it's part gospel meditation it's
part
musing on the romantic poets these
english poets from from centuries ago
it's a really terrific book head on over
to amazon or wherever you buy your books
order your copy of the truth and beauty
today we'll be right back with a lot
more
christie gnome governor of south dakota
has just banned
critical race theory not only in k-12
schools but at the college level as well
i brought two bills this legislative
session
that banned critical race theory from
being taught in our classrooms in our
k-12 schools and another one that banned
it in our universities the legislature
supported and passed and i signed into
law the university one
so now in south dakota going forward
critical race theory
and cannot be taught in our universities
they killed the k-12 one
so tomorrow i will be signing an
executive order to make sure
that critical race theory is not taught
to our kids in our public school systems
too
[Applause]
you go girl i like it it's great i'm not
sure if this has any teeth as she says i
brought these bills before the
legislature and they got shot down so
i'm signing an executive order executive
orders can be pretty weak so the devil's
in the details i hope it works
but the very fact that christinome is
doing this
shows you where the energy is on the
right
the squishes are going to tell you that
americans don't want to hear about the
cultural issues stay away from race stay
away from sex just focus on deregulation
and free trade and cutting taxes that
that was the
the common sense view on the right
and it's not true
it's not true we know it's not true
because glenn younkin tried to run that
campaign and he was losing and then he
turned his campaign on to transgenderism
and critical race theory and he won we
know it's not true because the most
popular governor in america right now is
ron desantis who's not running on the oh
let's all kumbayan get along and forget
about the cultural issues type of slogan
hearing in florida he's running on
kicking crazy gender theories out of
schools kicking crazy racial theories
out of schools and he's extremely
popular because of it both in florida
and nationally and christy gnome
is a weathervane
i i'm not saying this to insult
christinome good honor i'm glad that
she's
she's fighting for these policies
but christie gnome
infamously refused to protect women's
sports in college
she she had a bill come before her where
she where the bill was going to ban men
from competing in women's sports and she
shot it down
she later reversed herself on that but
she shot it down because who knows
because maybe she didn't want to lose
some sports competitions in south dakota
because i don't know again i'm just
speculating maybe she got some calls
from corporate sponsors of hers who
didn't like that she was going up
against transgenderism i don't know but
for whatever reason she shot it down
this should have been a slam dunk clear
case issue and she shot it down then she
got a ton of political blowback and her
political career at least at the
national level was almost over and so
she reversed herself you saw this with
asa hutchinson governor republican
governor in arkansas
ace hutchinson had a bill about banning
the transgenderism for kids come before
him and he said no i'm not going to do
that if a kid is being transgendered
right now i don't want to stop that
process why maybe it's just because he's
an idiot maybe it's because he's i'm not
even saying he has a low iq i'm saying
maybe it's because he's a moral idiot
who has no sense of right and wrong and
good and bad and is willing to to stand
by child abuse and actually encourage it
and applaud it maybe that's why or maybe
there's a more cynical answer maybe it's
because there are some big corporate
donors in arkansas and maybe he got a
phone call and they said hey governor
hutchinson back off the transgender
stuff and he caved i don't know it's
happened to a lot of politicians before
him wouldn't be surprised surprised if
that were the case
for hutchinson as well
very often
always really it's the case that he who
pays the piper calls the tune and so
you've got all of the entrenched
business interests all of the media
interests all of the
tech technology interests everything is
pushing these radical theories
however
there is one little glimmer of hope
which is that the people hate this crap
they especially hate the transgender
stuff and they especially hate critical
race theory and they hate it because
it's no longer even just affecting them
in the boardrooms it's affecting their
little kids in elementary schools and
then that's just a bridge too far
and so when we say he who pays the piper
calls the tune
the corporations who are throwing
billions and billions of dollars around
that's that's a big deal that's going to
influence things
the voters still have some say in
america
and as long as the voters still has have
some say the politicians are maybe going
to be a little bit responsive i don't
want to have too negative of you here or
too cynical a view of what christine is
doing whatever her motivations i'm glad
she's doing it's a good sign
coming up for the midterms now the
liberals
are claiming that this is not an issue
frankly critical race theory is not even
being taught in schools you're seeing
this not just from the honest and overt
liberals on msnbc and cnn you're seeing
it even from the fake republicans that
they bring on someone like anna navarro
anna navarro bills herself as a
republican strategist i'm not sure when
she's ever won a political campaign in
her life or even when she's really
worked on a campaign but republican
strategist just like democrat strategist
when you see that on tv usually that
means unemployed person giving an
opinion
so they don't know what to say so they
say you're a strategist okay all right
and that happens to a lot of people but
she's not an actual republican
strategist she's just a fake republican
who goes on tv to
put the republicans in their place she
goes on tv to say the liberals are right
about everything and so anna navarro
just tweeted out
repeatedly repeatedly
five six times crt is not being taught
to children crt is not being taught to
children crt is not being taught to
children my answer to her is
oh great
so then the bills banning crt
in kids classrooms they're not a big
deal
great it's not okay fine anna i take you
at your word
maybe
i tell
let's just go with the hypothetical crt
is not being taught to kids so then you
should have no problem with the bills
that are banning it i made this point to
ethan behrman who's a liberal friend of
mine goes on tv a lot
ethan
i i had him on this show
to talk about the florida parental
rights and education bill i said ethan
you're a sensible guy why on earth would
you oppose this bill and he said michael
it's just it's a non-issue
sexual ideology of any sort is not being
taught to kids in elementary schools in
preschool through third grade and i said
okay great well then what's the big deal
about banning it if it's not happening
then it's a non-issue and he said well
he realized the contradiction he
realized how he had just undermined his
own argument he said well but now maybe
it will be taught i said well no i
actually think it won't be taught now
because there's a bill outlawing it and
that was the stumbling block for him so
out of on the one hand the libs are
saying critical race theory is not being
taught to kids and then out of the other
side of their mouth they're saying and
it's a good thing that it is and it's a
big issue because you you've now got
little kids
being told that they are evil because of
their skin color
because they're white they're evil
and they're they're going through
exercises in elementary schools where
they have to line up on a on a
measure of privilege the whitest kids
are the most privileged and therefore
the most evil and the blackest kids are
the least privileged and therefore the
most virtuous
you've got exercises in elementary
schools where kids have to apologize
because they're white and this stuff is
so distasteful and preposterous even for
adults
right i think i don't know if it's
because of my sicilian heritage because
i've got a little touch of swarthiness
to me i am completely immune to white
guilt i just don't feel it i know that
white liberals feel it i know that some
white squish conservatives feel it i
don't feel it at all i don't think that
people ought to apologize for their skin
color i just it doesn't doesn't do
anything for me but i know that a lot of
a lot of conservatives they'll just
tolerate it when they inevitably get the
critical race theory trainings in the
corporate sphere or even in their
universities they'll just tolerate it
we're not going to tolerate it in
elementary schools this is a uniting
issue it unites
republicans with a lot of democrats it
unites white people with black people
who don't want this kind of racial
ideology with hispanic people with
with everyone else too
it's a big winner and it was one of the
real knocks on kitanji jackson who's the
judge who's going to be the next justice
on the supreme court the republicans are
almost certainly not going to be able to
stop her
her her nomination has now left the
judiciary committee it's going before
the entire senate
but but katanji jackson is the most
radical judge that we'll ever have had
in the history of the supreme court she
has praised the founder of critical race
theory one of the founders derek bell
she's praised the 1619 project which
pushes the ridiculous lie that the
american revolution was plot fought to
defend slavery even the new york times
doesn't defend that thesis anymore and
she's got a weird record on pedos where
she let pedos and child rapists off the
hook and she gave them much lower
sentences so she's she's got a really
really bad record
and dick durbin the chairman of the
judiciary committee
just basically apologized to her
for the horrible gop attacks the vi the
utterly vile things that republicans
have said about her during this
process on the whole my republican
colleagues starting with my ranking
member senator grassley
treated the nominee with dignity and
respect
they promised not to turn this
confirmation process into a quote circus
and most kept that promise some however
did not
instead they repeatedly interrupt and
badgered jackson and accused her of vile
things in front of her parents her
husband and her children
there was table pounding some literal
from a few of my colleagues they
repeated discredited claims about judge
jackson's record they impugned their
motives and questioned her candor one
all but called her a liar they even
suggested that judge jackson a mother to
two wonderful daughters quote endangers
children
judge jackson is a better person than me
she stayed calmed and collected she
showed dignity grace and poise
it is unfortunate that some moments in
our hearing came to that but if there is
one positive to take away from these
attacks on her it is that the nation saw
the temperament of a good strong person
ready to serve on the highest court of
the land
can you imagine politicians
smearing a supreme court nominee before
that nominee's children and spouse and
parent can you imagine
i can't fathoms oh wait a second
wasn't so long ago that brett kavanaugh
was nominated for the court and by the
way the treatment of kavanaugh and the
treatment of jackson
are
100
completely different utterly
incomparable different in kind
the vile things that democrats said
about brett kavanaugh
were completely without evidence they
were based on things that he allegedly
did
20
30 40 years prior
at high school parties
again have to emphasize this with no
evidence at all brought by completely
uncredible
lunatic women
like what's her what was the julie
swetnick who never met kavanaugh who was
being represented by some pimp lawyer
who's now a felon who's going behind
bars michael avenatti he was the man
that the democrats briefly wanted to
nominate for president but then now he's
behind bars and it's it's not impossible
to run for president from behind bars
eugene debs did it but it's it's not
easy or christine blasey ford who
changed her story a hundred times uh and
and again there's no evidence that she
ever even met brett kavanaugh those
they called kavanagh a gang rapist based
on nothing with katanji jackson what
were the attacks on her
the senators just read her own court
opinions
they just read her own record
and they deduced from that that she's a
threat to children she is a threat to
children she let pedos off the hook she
is a threat to children she let not even
just people consuming child porn off the
hook that's bad enough she let actual
child rapists off the hook and we
covered this on the show yesterday and
then one of them goes out and tries to
rape another woman while he should have
been in prison but he wasn't imprisoned
because katanji jackson let him off the
hook
and and by the way these the attacks on
katanji jackson were not were not
irrelevant to her work as a judge forget
about reading her actual record
obviously that's fair game but when
marsha blackburn asks katanji jackson
hey what's a woman that is very relevant
to her work as a judge one if she
doesn't know the answer then she's so
stupid that she must have gone to
harvard two times but two
she's going to have to adjudicate cases
that are that that rest on women's
rights things like title ix if you don't
know what a woman is you can't
adjudicate that sort of thing
when when you ask judge jackson her view
on natural rights she said she didn't
have a view of natural rights that's
going to affect her jurisprudence the
treatment of judge jackson was
completely fair completely incomparable
to what happened to brett kavanaugh and
she is going to be the furthest left
member of the court we've ever had to
quote a great man
sad
speaking of vile things not the
the vile things said about catanji
jackson but genuinely vile things
this might be
this is one of my least favorite told
you so's
that i've i've ever had the displeasure
of of doing
the conservatives are always accused of
slippery slope arguments
oh you you don't want to go along with
some radical change in society because
you think that some crazy absurd thing
is going to happen as a consequence of
it down the line that's a slippery slope
fallacy conservatives and every time
every time that we predict some other
degrading development will occur in our
society as a result of some decision
occurring right now
every time we predict the slippery slope
it comes true
we predict it that if you change the
definition of marriage
soon enough you're going to change the
definition of sex in the human person
and obviously the whole definition of
the family and you're going to get
transgenderism obviously that happened
we predict that if you legalize abortion
into any degree you're going to go from
not merely a tepid defense of of legal
abortion but a full-throated endorsement
you're going to go from safe legal and
rare abortion to abortion on demand
without apology shadow from the rooftops
that happened
one thing we predicted was that if you
lift the traditional social and
political restrictions on
sexual activity and you redefine
marriage and you redefine the whole
family and you say that now sexual
morality just amounts to if it feels
good do it
you're going to have people not just
having sex
with
each other whichever consenting adult
you want
not even just having sex with kids
which
the grooming thing is on the rise and no
one can deny it
you can have people having sex with
animals that's what we said and everyone
laughed at us and they said oh you're
you're a tin foil hat wearing kooky
crazy alex jones person
daily mail headline today bestiality
brothels are quote spreading through
germany warren's campaigner as abusers
turn to sex with animals as a lifestyle
lifestyle choice
bestiality brothels are spreading
through germany faster than ever thanks
to a law that makes animal porn illegal
but sex with animals legal a livestock
officer has warned
madeleine martin told the frankfurter
runshow
that current laws
for protecting animals from predatory
zoophiles that means people who stoop
animals
are
are not working because these people are
increasingly defending it as a lifestyle
choice
even people listening to the story right
now they might say oh that's crazy
that's tabloid madness no there's no way
that you could you can't possibly
defend having sex with animals as a
lifestyle choice you there's no way to
possibly normalize that these are the
people who all said no one would ever
normalize pedophilia which is occurring
right now they're even trying to change
the word for pedophile to minor
attracted person they're trying to
reduce the penalties for pedophiles
actually our next supreme court justice
did just that when she was
planning policy and when she was sitting
on the bench
they say there's no way you could ever
do it with animals
why
why well the argument is because animals
can't consent sure kids can't consent
and we're now not not only are people
reducing the stigma for having sex with
children or consuming child abuse images
now we're saying that children should be
allowed to lop off their genitals
if if a 16 or 17 year old can't consent
to having sex with a
20 or 21 year old and that's what the
law said i think in most places that's
what the law says
why on earth could a six-year-old
consent to making not just a temporary
sexual choice but a permanent sexual
choice to fundamentally destroy his body
chemistry
and sterilize himself why could that
happen i don't know but the libs are
pushing that the white house is pushing
that
but furthermore
why does consent matter in our
dealings with animals
we eat them
i don't i don't think the animal can
sense to be eaten does it
we skin them and wear their skin as our
clothing
we do everything we do with animals as
non can even when you're just
ordinarily sort of shepherding the
animals growing fur and they're growing
growing wool on the sheep and doing all
sorts of things it's not consensual
you're not getting a contract from the
sheep
not getting a contract from the cow we
send them to slaughter houses so if we
can kill the animals
if we can put them in terrible
conditions if we can wear their skin as
our clothing
why can't german perverts shoot the
animals
that seems less if we're saying that
rape is
a
one of the most grievous crimes but less
grievous perhaps than murder then why
why are we allowed to cut up the animals
and chop them up and eat them and have
them on our
dinner plate but german perverts aren't
allowed to stop them
you can't do it you can't there's no
argument from just consent that is going
to get you there okay and this
unfortunately on the left absolutely but
even on the right you've seen people
distill all morality about all things
not just sex but everything down to
consent well if if adults consenting
adults want to do it that's fine and
it's not the government's role to stop
them from doing it this is why you're
seeing people try to legal liberalize
drug laws this is why you're seeing
people liberalize laws against
mutilations against suicide for goodness
sakes well if people consent it's all
fine it's not it's not there's consent
is an important moral consideration but
there are other moral considerations too
what we're seeing in germany now
do not be surprised when nostradamus
predicted that this sort of thing was
coming
to america
speaking of the sexual revolution
we have a very important update from the
sexual revolution
the the other day blake masters tweeted
out in response to some leftist
provocation
he said not everything has to be gay
and he's wrong about that everything has
to be everything is going gay you know
this
it has it has to be because the sexual
revolution has to be complete it has to
this is why disney's going gay and trade
not even just gay it's going trans
everything has to partake of this
including
harry's razors that's why we stored in a
razor company jeremy's razors including
gillette razors actually for that matter
including every company we're starting
pride month a little early this year
pride month is in june and october now
we're starting it in april every company
is going to start changing their colors
to the rainbows
and this includes cookies
not only not only are they turning
the freaking frogs gay they are turning
the freaking oreo cookies gay
men dosha
jaren
i know you come from halfway around the
world
so we can have a better life
but i am here we go he's going what is
he going to say i am i think you're
ready gay once but
now the mother says i think you're ready
who's that at the door i don't know
because the whole family's there a
little girl eats an oreo cookie that's
the product placement in the movie
are you ready are you ready so the dad's
there it's not like he's got to tell the
dad
the mom's there it's not like he's got
to tell the mom the sister was there she
just ate the cookie
[Music]
and then we got some other extended
families coming in
oh and there's grandma
grand i guess grandma doesn't know that
this young man
is gay
you get the point we can wrap it there
the
radicalism of the is not just the gay
cookies it's going to give daily wire a
new opportunity oreos has gone gay
that's why we're so pleased to we're so
excited to unveil shaporio's the new
product of daily wire confections do you
want cookies without any sexual
indoctrination well sign up and get
shaporio's today
that's i want ben if you're listening
jeremy i want some royalties for
shiporios we're going to sell a lot of
them
i don't just bring it up to plug
whatever new product we're going to have
it's
the
uh
it's the perpetual revolution it's the
fact that even coming out once is not
enough you've got to come out of the
closet again and again and again just
getting this one law changed it's not
enough you got to do it again and again
just just winning on this one issue
pushing this issue no you've got it's
the perpetual revolution there is no end
to how far the left wants to take this
country it's not just transiting the 20
year olds it's transiting the 10 year
olds it's transiting the five-year-olds
if there's no
it's not just abortion in the first
trimester it's abortion up until the
moment of birth there's no
end unless we conservatives learn that
very important word
no i'm michael knowles that's the
michael knoll show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael noel show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 22.
today on the ben shapiro show barack
obama arrives back at the white house
and the media drool all over themselves
and meanwhile joe biden is just walking
around in the background and no one
wants to talk to him that's today on the
bench bureau show give it a listen